bonjour à tous bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires seller de parlement hebdo
avec mme moracchini bonjourbonjour
michael bonjour à tous et on va voir
tout ce qui s'est passé cette semaine
dans l'actualité politique et
parlementaire au menu un mois de folie
une guerre fratricide et au bout du
compte un accord global trouvé entre
françois fillon et jean françois copé un
nouveau vote devrait avoir lieu mi
septembre 2013
françois fillon se laisse jusqu'au mois
de juin pour se décider s'il sera ou pas
candidat dans deux fronts de ce haut
fait dans les rangs socialistes autour
du mariage pour tous
on attendait un bel accord sur le texte
mais les députés ps ont voté cette
semaine pour que soit déposé un
amendement sur la procréation
médicalement assistée
une minorité n'est pas d'accord et le
fait savoir
et puis fin d'année oblige nous ferons
le bilan quelles sont les personnalités
politiques de l'année 2012 qui fera
l'actualité en 2013 deux invités bruno
jeanbart de l'institut de sondages
opinionway nous rejoindra en fin
d'émission pour commenter cette dernière
semaine parlementaire denis baupin
bonjour merci d'être avec nous au député
écologiste de paris depuis six mois
maintenant et oui député encore
fraîchement élu on pourra dire mais déjà
l'un des vice-présidents de l'assemblée
nationale alors les parisiens vous
connaissent bien vous étiez maire
adjoint de paris parfois surnommé le
khmer vert pour votre intransigeance
notamment sur la circulation dans paris
m'a donné deux mois mais exactement j'ai
dit certains journaux mais comme ça de
la mairie de paris au palais bourbon
comment vous vois vos collègues députés
c'est charles villa neuve qui est allé
poser la question cette semaine hors
gamme
c'est quelqu'un que je trouve
sympathique qui a des convictions
qui s'est finalement vite mis à la
fonction de vice président c'était pas
évident puisqu'il n'avait jamais eu
l'occasion de présider un exécutif
quelconque et du coup ils trouvent
il a trouvé toute sa place c'est un
homme de sang froid donc illégales
il sait garder la maîtrise de lui-même
ce qui est très important politique et
dans la conduite des débats
c'est comme on dit en anglais de
reitmans de right place
il est le dilemme des verts j'allais
dire ils sont une phase ii dans une
fosse d'or là il faudra qu'un jour il
décide mais on peut pas être à la fois
dans la majorité
quand ça arrange et dans l'opposition
quand ça arrange c'est d'abord quelqu'un
de sympathique agréable
en tant que nouveau député nous sommes
tout de suite bien entendus et puis
c'est aussi quelqu'un que je croise dans
le métro donc c'est toujours bon signe
bon c'est bon signe pas de gros 4 4 dans
paris pour vous pour circuler vous êtes
en métro moi depuis toujours parce que
je veux être à leur ami rendez vous
savez le moyen de transport quand même
le plus fiable dans paris il ya pas de
doute ça n'assure collectif en tant que
président et sa place de bartoloni vous
il vous donne un satisfecit là une bonne
note
on est content c'est sympathique
pourtant il ya des moments où on vous a
bu subir un peu les foudres de
l'opposition que vous avez été au
perchoir on se rappelle notamment d'une
science avoir un budget sur le vote sur
l'agriculture on a vu notamment
christian jacob ou harangue est ce le
mépris du règlement futur
c'est une super le terme était le moins
très exagéré puisque après la conférence
des présidents a dit que j'avais bien
président et donc on vous sentez un peu
mal à l'aise au perchoir quand même
c'est difficile d'intégrer le règlement
d'un d'atterrir une maison comme celle
ci dans toute maison à ses codes donc
bon moi j'ai présidé très rarement le
conseil de paris pendant pendant 11 ans
quand même mis six coups il ya 160 et
lui donc c'est un hémicycle mais c'est
pas du tout les mêmes les maynats
fonctionnement galles c'est encore plus
particulier voilà c'est ça il ya une
situation très très fort d'abord parce
que c'est c'est on est on est sous les
projecteurs tout le temps si tout est
filmé et c'est donc et puis il ya d un
règlement très particulier on sait qu'on
vote la loi après donc c'est quand même
plus compliqué donc il faut apprendre un
petit peu les codes donc au début on
essaye de voir un petit peu comment ça
se passe et puis c'est vrai que je le
reconnais et je ne connais pas encore
les noms des 577 députés
rien qu'en les voyant donc colle pour
donner la parole par exemple c'est
parfois mais vous êtes déjà vice
président ce qui n'est pas donné à tout
le monde quand on vient d'être élu c'est
quoi c'est déjà ça va très vite pour
vous ou est ce qu'on vous a facilité un
peu les choses bah c'est à dire c'est
une répartition entre les familles
politiques donc on a eu un accord avec
les partis noirs solides à quelqu'un un
député qui est élu depuis plus longtemps
vous savez dans notre groupe il n'y en
avait que deux kits et des sortants un
noël mamère et l'arrière du rgi donc
françois de rugy le président noël
n'avait pas vraiment envie d'être vice
président donc voilà donc les paysans
oui c'est une tâche importante mais en
même temps c'est très intéressant enfin
vraiment de présider les séances voir
beaucoup de débats différents
beaucoup de ministres en activité
beaucoup de députés etc je trouve ça
passionnant il participe à la conférence
des présidents
c'est aussi le lieu où se décident
l'organisation de l'assemblée donc on
apprend très vite comme ça alors ça
c'est à l'assemblée mais on va parler
maintenant du sénat nous sommes lundi et
au sénat bien sûr après les communistes
on a parlé de votre parti les verts
vous faîtes entendre votre voix vous
aussi
françois hollande a beau multiplier les
sorties sur le terrain pour promouvoir
le crédit d'impôt compétitivité gains
reste que les partis qui composent sa
majorité eux ils restent hostiles à
l'exemple de ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end au sénat les explications de
fabrice qu'une et la grogne des
sénateurs verts couvait depuis plusieurs
mois en provoquant le rejet du crédit
d'impôt un pas et cette fois franchi car
ce cice est la mesure phare du
gouvernement
l'attitude des élus écologistes sonne
comme un avertissement
la commission des finances du sénat
vient d'estimer le coût réel de ce
crédit d'impôt non pas de 20 milliards
mais de 24,3 milliards d'euros donc on
peut se demander si le gouvernement dans
sa volonté de faire vite et d'agir vite
pour relancer l'activité n'est pas aller
trop vite
en tous les cas il a loupé une étape
c'est celle de dialoguer d'échanger
d'écouter et de trouver des aménagements
avec les membres de sa majorité
alors les élus verts peuvent ils jouer
la dissidence systématique appliquée par
le groupe communiste
l'idée pour l'instant rejetée encore
faudrait-il que le gouvernement change
de méthode et la majorité sénatoriale
est en difficulté mais elle n'a pas été
mise
abba et je pense que cette majorité peut
se retrouver dès l'instant où chacun a
le sentiment d'être peut-être un peu
plus écoutés c'est apparemment ce qu'on
en attend de nous pour certains élus
socialistes le gouvernement jouerait
avec le feu fort d'une majorité solide à
l'assemblée il resterait sourd aux
appels à la concertation lancée au sénat
au risque de voir les sénateurs est
réduit à un simple rôle d'observateur
alors denis baupin c'est vrai que c'est
tentant n'avait plus vu les communistes
comme frondeurs maintenant ce sont les
verts qui se servent du sénat comme
défouloir non pas des fois nous voulons
peser sur la politique menée par le
gouvernement nous faisons partie de la
majorité c'est vrai que la revendication
que peuvent avoir les communistes et ils
ont légitimité pour le faire puisqu'il
avait appelé à voter pour françois
hollande au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
mais nous qui sommes en plus membre du
gouvernement nous voulons participer à
la prise de décision à l'assemblée vous
êtes abstenu sur cette partie du texte
du crédit d'impôt on est tous et qu'on
leur fasse du notte entre les cci vous a
pu remarquer que c'était pas exactement
les mêmes compositions au sénat à
l'assemblée nationale nous essayons de
jouer sur les leviers qui sont à notre
disposition au faire passer le message à
nos partenaires que on peut vouloir
faire évoluer les règles de l'économie
bien évidemment nous y sommes très
favorables mais que nous voulons que ça
soit utile pour faire la transition
énergétique et écologique qui est
importante pas simplement faire plaisir
aux écolos et parce que nous pensons que
cela que se situent les emplois d'avenir
et ses terres le démonstration que
l'allemagne aujourd'hui dans sa
transition industrielle énergétique
c'est plus de 400000 emplois qui ont été
créés dans les énergies renouvelables
donc il ya vraiment des potentialités
très importante donc plutôt que de faire
un crédit d'impôt qui soit non ciblés
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
nous avons fait passer les amendements à
l'assemblée nationale notamment un
disant qu'elle favorise la transition
énergétique donc que nous nous voulons
faire cela de la même façon que sur la
tva
nous pensons que on ne doit pas un
indistinctement augmenter les taux de
tva sur sambre de travaux par exemple le
logement social la réhabilitation
thermique des bâtiments les transports
collectifs
tout ça est utile pour la transition
écologique et énergétique et donc nous
voulons faire en sorte qu'on n'augmente
pas la tva parce que ça va défavorisés
de niveau
entendez le sénateur socialiste dans ce
dans ce reportage qui disait c'est
peut-être besoin d'être entendus nita
que vous avez ce manque aujourd'hui dans
le gouvernement de jean marc ayrault et
dans cette majorité de français mais pas
assez entendu vous ça dépend des sur
europe écologie les verts ale pendant
les sujets sur la banque publique
d'investissement par exemple on a
travaillé ensemble entre groupes de la
majorité et on a pu faire avancer des
idées
donc c'est la preuve que on peut trouver
des méthodes sur la fiscalité écologique
un travail est en train de s'entamer
donc nous espérons bien que nous
pourrons être entendu et faire peser sur
les décisions qui seront prises sur le
crédit d'impôt
franchement ça s'est passé extrêmement
vite il n'y a pas eu de concertation en
amont et ça ça crée tous les deux on
peut s'attendre à d'autres sorties comme
ce qui s'est passé au sénat pour pouvoir
essayer de peser un petit peu plus c'est
pas notre bureau l'année 2013
notre but est plutôt d'être entendu de
concerter d'abord mais s'il ya des
occasions où on n'a pas été entendu on
est en désaccord avec les textes en
effet on le fait savoir
mais on l'a fait savoir aussi au mont du
traité européen par exemple voilà on est
on est pas on n'est pas dans cette
majorité on s'en rappelle d'ailleurs oui
oui je sais quand ils nous en veulent en
partie mais si on devait voter comme des
socialistes c'était pas la peine de
faire un référé de faire élire des
députés et les sénateurs écologistes
nous sommes là pour apporter aussi
d'autres idées d'autres convictions qui
sont celles des électeurs qui nous ont
élus alors les états d'âme atteignent
parfois aussi les rangs socialistes en
ce lundi une quinzaine d'élus ps signant
dans le parisien une tribune dans
laquelle ils demandent en substance à
françois hollande de revenir aux
fondamentaux sociaux de la gauche
on va écouter l'un des initiateurs de ce
texte est la réponse du ps nous disons
revenons aux fondamentaux du discours du
bourget comment françois hollande a pu
être élu parce qu'ils aient eu le
soutien des catégories populaires qui
sont venus vers nous déçu par la
présidence des riches de nicolas sarkozy
et attendant d'avoir une présidence du
pouvoir d'achat que les parlementaires
alimente le débat et contribuer à ce
débat pour au pointé la nécessité
de de continuer et de faire des efforts
dans ce domaine est tout à fait
important mais le parti socialiste
marche sur ses deux pieds
jamais la gauche qui a fait ses réformes
sociales et qui continue à les faire n'a
mis en opposition quelconque les
réformes sociétales qu'elle a engagée et
qui marque aussi l'identité de la gauche
vous auriez pu signer cette tribune on
s'était aliéné forcément celle là mais
dire en tout cas que il y a un besoin de
pilotage et de compréhension plus fort
entre nous sur là où nous voulons aller
dans la politique qui est menée par le
gouvernement en matière économique
notamment mais je le disais
industrielles énergétiques pour nous
c'est un bloc 1 se dire que nous faisons
l'analyse aujourd'hui que la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes n'est pas une crise
conjoncturelle qui suffirait de refaire
un peu relance et de croissance pour en
sortir mais une crise beaucoup plus
structurelle il n'y a pas de ligne
directrice
nous pensons qu'en effet aujourd'hui il
y à un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont prises comme le crédit d'impôt pain
qui sont arrivés très vite c'était pas
prévu trouver dans le programme de
françois hollande
ban de fait un peu un peu trop vite
parce qu'elle n'a pas été totalement
discuter concertée et réfléchie pour
regarder comment on pouvait mieux cibler
alors nous avons entendu les messages du
ministre de l'économie disant qu' on
pouvait faire évoluer le dispositif dans
le temps donc c'est le rôle que nous
nous assignons en tant que député membre
de la majorité de faire en sorte que à
la fois sur le crédit d'impôt sur la tva
sur la fiscalité écologique on a une
politique qui disent clairement que les
autorités c'est ce que vous demandez en
fait oui fera plus de clarté avec dans
le sens de ce que nous souhaitons
évidemment à tant qu'à faire ses passes
et pas seulement une question de méthode
c'est aussi de dire c'est quoi la grande
orientation que ce gouvernement veut
donner à sa politique économique et nous
pensions qu'elle doit se traduire par
une politique énergétique industriel qui
aille va te dire c'est que ça manque
vraiment d'une ligne directrice
oui mais quand je regarde nous - arnaud
montebourg par exemple ministre du
redressement productif qui fait beaucoup
de d'agitation etc nous avons vraiment
le sentiment qu'il est sur une ligne
très défensive theron défend tout ce qui
est menacée et pas du tout sur une
prospective dire essayons de voir qu'est
ce qui peut faire émerger
demain une nouvelle filière il ya
peut-être plus d'emplois à créer demain
dans
les énergies renouvelables dans la
médiation thermique que de dire encore
les gaz de schiste c'est extrêmement
intéressant
d'abord c'est pas intéressant ça d'un
point de vue écologique ça posait dans
mon problème et en plus c'est très peu
créateur d'emplois au mythe et qui a été
mis en place cette semaine pour
réfléchir sur la fiscalité verte
notamment la taxation plus lourde du
diesel vous avez quand même des vous
êtes optimiste sur sur cette avancée la
sueur jeu à la fois parce que nous
portons la volonté que la fiscalité soit
un outil pour réduire les nuisances elle
est vraiment les nuisances liées et au
diesel sont sûrs lui contesté par
personne et en plus parce que de fait il
ya besoin d'argent donc de fait on on
peut concilier deux impératifs à la fois
de diminuer les nuisances et en même
temps récolté au travers de la fiscalité
des moyens pour faire la transition par
si on ne sait pas ce que deux jours
supplémentaires ça oui c'est bien pour
ça qu'on a composé plus il faut en
conséquence que des mesures soient mises
en place avec l'argent qu'ils
récoltaient pour aider les gens se
passer le diesel renforcer les
transports collectifs faire en sorte que
quelqu'un cameron à un véhicules très
polluants puisse avoir la gratuité des
transports collectifs pendant deux ans
par exemple
voilà des mesures qui vont permettre de
faire cette évolution mais il faut bien
constater que plus on retarde les
mesures nécessaires plus ça coûtera cher
c'est pour c'est ce qui se passe sur le
diesel ça fait 20 ans qu'on sait que
c'est dangereux pour la santé
personne n'a jamais rien voulu faire et
progressivement le parc c'est de plus en
plus d elise est évidemment là comme on
prend le virage ça apparaît encore plus
douloureux quand je vous écoute
j'attends juste une chose il ya un
manque de dialogue caractéristiques
autres caractérisée entre vous et le
gouvernement
est-ce que ça va pouvoir durer longtemps
eh ben j'ai noté que cette semaine nos
partis politiques respectifs le vin
socialiste et europe écologie les verts
ont décidé de constituer des groupes de
travail pour réfléchir ensemble
je pense que nos ministres est un
évènement tout cas essayer d'améliorer
le dialogue nous nous sommes partie
prenante de la majorité et nous allons y
rester pour ceux qui se posent parfois
la question ne vend aucun eu envie de
faire le plaisir à ceux qui voudraient
nous voit sortir de sortir ces penseurs
au lobby nucléaire au lobby des ogm à
surgères et bah non on est au
gouvernement pour pour peser à
l'intérieur des institutions alors parlé
d'un autre parti c'est mardi l'armistice
à l'ump enfin
alors ils ont sûrement pas fait exprès
mais la guerre à l'ump a duré un mois
pile en ce mardi à l'assemblée c'est la
grande réunion de l'unité pour célébrer
l'accord trouvé entre les frères ennemis
il y aura de nouvelles élections pour la
présidence du parti en septembre
prochain sous le contrôle d'une autorité
indépendante content mais encore
prudents les parlementaires jérémy
hartmann à satisfaction et soulagement
sur les visages du clan copé
mais pour l'image de la réconciliation
il faudra patienter
françois fillon et ses lieutenants sont
encore absents de la photo de famille
quand est ce qu'on aura la chandeleur
l'image tous ensemble une la famille
réunie
alors vous allez la voir très vite très
vite écoutez nous nous l'étions tout à
l'heure et puis voilà maintenant
maintenant là la vie va reprendre son
cours après ces trois semaines qui ont
été très douloureuse pour nous tous pour
les pour les pour les militants de l'ump
pour les français je crois que
maintenant il faut il faut vraiment
tourné la page se tournait vers l'avenir
voilà donc l'objectif de ce bureau
politique extraordinaire de l'ump même
si pour l'instant jean françois copé
préfère ne pas se prononcer sur sa
candidature au nouveau vote de septembre
prochain
françois fillon se donne lui jusqu'à
juin pour prendre sa décision
en attendant à l'assemblée les députés
ump pouvait enfin retrouvé leur rôle
d'élu d'opposition
ce qui est dramatique c'est d'avoir un
gouvernement qui est tellement
prisonniers
des querelles idéologiques une journée
pour oublier ce mardi matin
sénateurs et députés de chaque camp
était réunie à l'initiative de bernard
accoyer pour enterrer la hache de guerre
les compteurs ce show steve sont remis à
zéro et on va il n'y a pas de vainqueur
il n'y a pas de vaincu mais cet accord
résistera-t-il jusqu'au nouveau scrutin
prévue dans dix mois
certains restent encore méfiants ça sera
difficile bien sûr c'est pas comme ça
aux mains instant par l'opération du
saint-esprit qu'on va oublier les
petites phrases
bah oublier les mots
laksaci c'est mieux qu' un accord vous
n'êtes pas totalement convaincu qui
viennent fb - sushi chichi moi je suis
convaincu qui tiendra maintenant
j'espère que ce sera un climat de
confiance parce que si constamment ses
de la défiance
c'est un peu pénible de durer neuf mois
comme ça à l'assemblée le groupe
dissident créé par françois fillon sera
dissous en janvier prochain
quand les lieutenants de l'ex premier
ministre pourront intégrer la direction
provisoire du parti
un denis baupin j'ai l'habitude de la
guerre des chefs chez les écologistes
si on veut vous l'avez vous la regardez
comment celle là un peu l'impression
d'un replâtrage
mais en fait rien n'est résolu c'est à
dire que de fait la crise de l'ump ce
n'est pas simplement une guerre des
chefs
c'était comme un ou deux lignes
politiques différentes c'est l'héritage
du sarkozysme combats d'ego mais chacun
chacun rôle de dire que cette deux
lignes politiques différentes
il faut bien constater la stratégie
suivie par nicolas sarkozy à la première
élection présidentielle la deuxième et
entreprend tout sombre son quinquennat a
été quand même une droitisation de plus
en plus importante de la droite
républicaine
françois fillon essaye de retrait
incarné en quelque sorte un héritage
plutôt de cette droite républicaine of
jean françois copé lui reste sur une
ligne très droitière ces deux lignes
très différentes et cesser de ligne qui
s'affrontent
et aujourd'hui alors c'est le hasard qui
a fait arithmétiquement qui sont tombés
quasiment à 50 50 mais ce problème là
n'est pas résolu donc là ils peuvent
refaire un replâtrage pour faire pour
arrêter la guéguerre politicienne mais
comme ils repartent pour des élections
et que surtout ils n'ont pas cherché à
avoir un débat en profondeur sur la
ligne politique et sur les désaccords
qu'ils avaient entre eux à mon avis il y
en a encore pour un moment
alors la lave aux deux candidats à la
primaire on oublie vite mais bon eva
joly et nicolas hulot qui s'était bien
affronter à l'époque ils ont totalement
disparu de l'horizon de votre parti qui
est votre chef aujourd'hui qui est votre
leader naturel si on se projette sur
2010 est facile duflot ministre pascal
durand
quatre ans et demi donc nous venons
d'avoir une élection présidentielle la
sueur présidentialisation de la vie
politique on vient de le voir avec l'ump
ces séjours iv mais c'est extrêmement
dramatique on n'était pas obligé de le
faire tous pareils n'a pas besoin d'un
leader plusieurs livres évidemment ce
style qui est aujourd'hui la principale
de nos deux noms ministre évidemment bon
signe d'avoir un rôle de leadership
mais daniel cohn-bendit a aussi un rôle
de leadership par c'était celui qui a
conduit nos listes aux élections
européennes il est président de groupe
au parlement européen il jouera un rôle
dans la campagne européenne
j'en suis certain parce que c'est un
européen convaincu oui mais pas trop
vite c'est ce que nous avons pascal
durand évidemment inquiet aujourd'hui
sur quatre national du parti
enfin il ya un certain nombre de leaders
aujourd'hui qui se complètent et qui
donc c'est pas c'est pas indispensable
aujourd'hui et puis vous avez parlé de
nicolas hulot il va il a enroulé a pas
pour le parti puisqu'il est il s'est mis
en retrait par rapport à notre
organisation politique ma foi il va
avoir un rôle auprès de françois
hollande qui est un rôle important
intéressant utile et moi je suis content
qu'ils les écologistes un peu partout
qui pèsent le développeur va changer de
sujet à présent on va parler d'un sujet
qui suscite évidemment beaucoup de
débats celui de la fin de vie le
professeur didier sicard a remis son
bilan son rapport à françois hollande
pas d'euthanasie mais la possibilité
d'accélérer par un geste médical la fin
de vie ce projet sera examiné au mois de
juin prochain le détail avec françois
goulard du rapport de 200 pages
françois hollande en a retenu trois
points qu'ils comptent intégrer dans un
projet de loi sur la fin de vie au mois
de juin prochain
d'abord les directives anticipées plus
accessible il s'agirait d'un formulaire
signé par un adulte bien portant et un
médecin en cas de maladie grave pour
clarifier ses volontés sur la fin de vie
deuxième point les soins palliatifs le
rapport préconise leur généralisation et
un suivi du patient dès l'annoncé de la
maladie
concernant le suicide assisté le
rapporteur y est favorable aux
législateurs à présent d'en décider mais
la loi ne doit pas aller plus loin
préconise-t-il je pense que la médecine
peut avoir vocation à aider quelqu'un à
mourir
elle n'a pas vocation à donner la mort
de façon radicale comme on le fait
éventuellement dans les condamnations à
mort ou pour un animal c'est à dire une
injection de curare pour les
associations favorables à l'euthanasie
le rapport est une copie conforme de la
loi léonetti qui existe depuis 2005
pire les membres de la commission sont
tous des opposants à l'euthanasie assure
le président de la dmd l'association
pour le droit à mourir dans la dignité
la composition de la mission nous a
étonné dès le départ une fois de plus on
a donné ça un grand médecin alors que
c'est une affaire citoyenne 8 sur 10
étaient des personnes qui étaient contre
la légalisation de l'euthanasie
avant de trancher en juin prochain le
président veut une nouvelle consultation
celle du comité consultatif national
d'éthique mais d'euthanasie active
il n'en sera pas question la promesse 21
du candidat hollande disait simplement
une assistance médicalisée pour terminer
sa vie dans la dignité
denis baupin on le voit cette la loi
léonetti existent elles datent de 2005
pas ou peu appliquée par les médecins
était-il nécessaire utile de créer ce
nouvel outil cette nouvelle loi qui
arrivera au mois de juin c'est un
engagement de françois hollande
donc il fallait absolument parce que
c'est un engagement de françois hollande
l'a créée à partir du moment où on a
pris l'engagement devant les électeurs
j'espère que chacun pense que or il doit
être tenu en tout cas c'est notre
conviction la loi léonetti telle qu'elle
est et n'étaient pas suffisantes pour la
suffisance dont on voit d'ailleurs avec
le nombre de situations aujourd'hui où
le droit il ya des problèmes juridiques
importants par rapport à des situations
dans lesquelles on se retrouve on
constate que finalement il ya des
suicides assistés ou des procédures
d'euthanasie active dans la réalité qui
pose problème des gens qui veulent
mourir parce que ils sont arrivés en fin
de vie il considère qu'il souffre trop
que et donc ils veulent être aidé il
demande de l'aide
et ceux qui les aident se retrouve
devant la justice il ya quelque chose
qui ne qui ne tient pas donc ça fait je
ne dis pas que la question est simple
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
rapport sicard apporte quelques petites
améliorations mais vraiment très peu
c'est pas c'est pas la hauteur de
l'engagement pris par le président
république lé l'actualité encore le
mardi l affaire deux par dieu continue
de planer sur l'hémicycle l'acteur a
menacé de rendre son passeport français
on le sait s'estimant insultés notamment
par le premier ministre écoutez 7
entre le député ump fraîchement réélu
patrick devedjian et le ministre du
budget durant ces six derniers mois
vous avez augmenté très fortement 25
impôts 25 impôts je vous renvoie à ce
que disait si intelligemment abraham
lincoln vous ne vous ne pouvez pas aider
le pauvre en ruinant le riche entre 2003
et 2006 le nombre d'exilés fiscaux est
passé de 3 168 à 843 et pourtant me
semble-t-il dans cette mandature
vous n'avez pas été vous à l'ump en
arrière de la main pour baisser les
impôts et pourtant le nombre de départs
vos raisons fiscales a été multiplié par
2,5 entre 2007 et 2012 pour prendre une
période plus récente
vous avez voté et longtemps défendu le
bouclier fiscal en espérant voir revenir
certains qu'ils étaient expatriés vers
des cieux plus fiscaux plus fiscalement
clément et bien il se trouve que aucun
retour substantiel n'avait été observé
denis baupin un chiffre que l'on entend
cette semaine cinq mille exilés fiscaux
depuis l'arrivée de françois hollande
chiffres non confirmés 1
il n'y a pas un problème quand même une
fiscalité sur les plus riches
problème le gens qui gagnent trop
d'argent mais quand je l'entends gérard
depardieu de se plaindre d'avoir payé
145 millions 145 millions d'euros
d'impôts sur 40 ans jeudi ses 85 %
d'impôt cumulée aux travaux mais moi
j'aimerais avoir payé 145 millions
d'euros
mais imaginez l'argent que je gagne
cette personne est ce que finalement il
a il a par rapport à ce que travail
las mikari là il a vraiment l'apport à
la société tellement important qu'il
gagne autant d'argent il ya eu peut-être
quand il ya des milliers d'emplois à la
clé quand des entrepreneurs part on voit
en lin alain afflelou qui qui va partir
à lons dans la bon est ce que est ce
qu'on décourage pas un peu les oui
est-ce qu'on décourage pas finalement un
petit peu l'esprit d'entreprise tout ce
qu'on entend depuis zéro penser que tous
ces genres donc l'esprit d'entreprise
c'est l'esprit je me ramasse le plus
d'argent possible pour moi même c'est ça
que ça veut dire parce que 6 cyl
la seule raison pour laquelle les gens
pour s expatrier c'est parce que ils
doivent participer la société nationale
pas à 75%
soyons clairs c'est des franges d'impôts
un progressif donc il faut que les
choses soient dites clairement ça c'est
une bonne chose et donc le on a laissé
penser que tout d'un coup il y avait
quelque chose de confiscatoire d'un
fiscalité non il ya juste on remet de la
progressivité nous d'ailleurs nous
sommes plutôt favorable à ce qu'on dit
tranche intermédiaire entre les 45% et
les 75%
il faut qu'ils la progressivité parce
que c'est normal de contribuer on ne
peut pas dire que des gens comme gérard
depardieu par exemple n'est pas
bénéficier de l'ensemble de ce que la
société française peut apporter
donc c'est normal que quand on gagne
autant d'argent on y contribuer prouve
que il devrait un peu se poser la
question de savoir quand il est soutenu
par vladimir poutine
si en terme d'image par rapport à
l'ensemble de ceux qui le respectent et
et l'admirer en tant qu'acteur il a
vraiment beaucoup de vrai pour propose
que ce qu'ils voulait porter caution de
seconde sur le fond trop d'impôts tuent
la pause si vous connaissez ce vieil
adage ou pas oui enfin d'accord mais à
partir de la question
n'dri parce que quand il ya moi je veux
bien qu'on regarde sur les dix ans qui
sont passés et notamment pendant tout le
temps où sous l'ère sarkozy
on a réduit énormément les impôts après
on vous a dit que les caisses sont vides
ah bah oui on a fait des cadeaux des
cadeaux fiscaux d un bouclier fiscal des
réductions d'impôts sur les plus riches
etc
et puis après on nous dit les questions
vite bah oui c'est logique si on ne
récolte plus l'argent dis-donc et donc
il est logique de revenir à quelque
chose qui soit l'année c'est soit on
veut démanteler le système de service
public français donc que ceux qui le
propose l'assument
soit on estime qu'on en a besoin et donc
il faut le financer et il est légitime
que ceux qui gagnent le plus soit ceux
qui contribuent le plus à l'est mercredi
les députés socialistes s'accordent ou
presque sur le mariage pour tous
la question du jour faut-il intégrer la
pma la procréation médicalement assistée
dans le texte du mariage pour tous
en ce mercredi les députés socialistes
se réunissent pour en décider
et ce sera oui un amendement sera ajouté
au texte mais le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que ce oui et prononcé du
bout des lèvres un valérie brochard le
chef des députés socialistes a réussi à
convaincre les deux tiers de son groupe
pour lui
l'amendement sur la pma a toute sa place
dans le texte de loi sur le mariage pour
tous
le groupe a pris la décision de déposer
un amendement sur la pma aux textes qui
viendra en discussion le 29 janvier
le texte n'est pas encore rédigée mais
son contenu déjà connue l'accès à la pma
pour les couples de femmes mariées une
position rejetée par 61 députés de la
majorité qui seront pourtant contraints
de voter cet amendement
ce n'est pas anormal qu'on demande à
tous les membres du groupe de se tenir à
cette position
ils peuvent ne pas être présent donné
leur pouvoir au moment du vote
mais pas de liberté de vote ça veut dire
qu'on leur demande de ne pas voter
contre la position du groupe auquel ils
appartiennent appartenir à un groupe c
des droits et des devoirs et donc parmi
les devoirs il y à celui de respecter la
discipline de son groupe
la discipline pas toujours évidente au
sein du groupe majoritaire
certains parlementaires aurait préféré
plus de tant d'autres un cadre différent
moi j'ai voté contre introduction de la
pma dans le texte
du gouvernement sur le mariage et à
l'autre chante pour tous parce que je
considère que ce débat là nous ne sommes
pas prêts et qu'on ne peut pas
improviser sur un sujet comme celui ci
moi je me suis abstenu je pense qu'il
faut pas se précipiter sur ce sujet on a
besoin d'un peu de temps ça sujet
compliqué juridiquement
philosophiquement et qu' il n'y a pas de
raison d'aller vite dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée
il se murmure que cet amendement ne
serait en réalité que la mort ceux d'un
débat plus large avec l'engagement du
gouvernement de proposer la pma dans une
réforme complète des lois bioéthique ou
dans une loi spécifique sur la famille
alors 27 députés socialistes ont même
signé une pétition demandant que leur
nom soit retiré de l'amendement pma le
texte arrivera fin janvier à l'assemblée
à ce que le groupe écologiste va être
unanimement pour cet amendement pma non
seulement nous sommes pour cet
amendement pema mais je voudrais aussi
dire que nous sommes tout à fait pour
cette grande avancée que va être le
droit au mariage pour tous et le droit à
l'adoption
nous revendiquons l'égalité des droits
voilà la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui c'est de donner les mêmes
droits à ceux qui sèment dans des
couples homosexuels que ceux qui sèment
dans les couples hétérosexuels
c'est aussi simple que ça et donc les
questions qui sont posées aujourd'hui
sur la pma par exemple doivent être
posées de la même façon aux couples
homosexuels en couple aux hétérosexuels
si on s'y attendait problème par rapport
à la pma qu'ils déposent les accords
c'est pour les femmes et couples de
femmes
6 pour les hommes bien évidemment on
passe à la gpa qui est encore une étape
supplémentaire
est-ce que là on est on est pas quand
même dans des lois bioéthiques plus que
dans une loi comme ça sur le mariage
pour tous
non je pense que sur cette question de
la pma c'est ce débat il est il est
porté depuis longtemps tout le monde le
connaît même si aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de députés socialistes et c'est
légitime qui est du débat à chaque fois
qu'ils aient des grandes avancées
sociétales quand ça a été sur le divorce
constat était sur les vg et c c'est tout
ça tout ça remue et fait débat dans la
société puis progressivement la société
évolue personne n'imaginerait
aujourd'hui revenir en arrière sur la
peine de mort sur les vj et c'est donc
de fait mais dans le moment enix équipe
qui fait recette amendement dans ce
texte là sur le mariage pour tous et ce
qu'il ne faut pas texte à part c'est la
question pourquoi faudrait-il attaque sa
part n'est pas parce qu'ils ont fait
c'est là il s'agit de peaufiner mais
c'est pas ce pourquoi ce serait trop tôt
c'est ça fait dix années de mépris
prix socialiste l'hypothèque les attend
une très large majorité des députés
socialistes
il est réputé très très très large qui
est favorable
et donc voilà ccc n'étaient pas décédés
du groupe socialiste moi je ne me sais
pas combien ils étaient présents à
s'amuser moi j'ai pas vu pas toutes ces
informations là mais la majorité vote au
sein au sein de ce groupe il ya une
volonté majoritaire de faire avancer ses
droits et d'avoir une égalité des droits
entre les couples hétérosexuels et vous
vous exposez votre propre groupe parce
que ce sont des questions qui ne sont
pas simples où il ya parfois des cas par
cas sur ces sujets que l'on a évoqué la
ja oui on a on est d'accord entre nous
sur la question de par exemple de la gpa
ce sera quelque chose qui est plus
compliqué je vais juste vous parliez
d'égalité il ya quand même pour les voir
et pour les amener sur la gpa
quelle que ce que ce soit pour des
couples hétérosexuels ou homosexuels
la question se pose pour nous voilà donc
on ne fait pas de différence les types
de couple par contre sur les techniques
qui sont peuvent être utilisés nous
faisons un débat où nous avons un débat
sur est ce que est ce que la gpa est
aujourd'hui une avancée importante
c'est quelque chose que quand même assez
compliqué vous craignez la manifestation
du mois de janvier où vous allez
finalement retrouvé une opposition unie
sur ce sujet écoutez il faut y
manifester c'est bien leurs droits en
moi et j'ai manifesté de très nombreuses
fois et je contre-manifester encore pour
le droit au mariage
il est légitime de le droit de
manifestation est un droit important
mais pour autant les électeurs ont voté
nous avons pris un engagement devant les
électeurs lors des élections
présidentielles et lors des élections
législatives les deux fois les électeurs
ont voté majoritairement pour des
candidats qui portaient ces propositions
allaient jeudi marquée par les mots
souffrance et colonisation
pas d' excuses pas de repentance mais
une reconnaissance de la brutalité de la
colonisation
voilà pour le message adressé par
françois hollande devant les
parlementaires lors de son voyage en
algérie tous les détails avec paul
bouffard la vérité doit être dite devant
le parlement algérien ville
le président français reconnaît que la
france a manqué à ses valeurs
universelles la veille françois hollande
ne voulait pas faire d' excuses ni faire
repentance
aujourd'hui il dénonce le système
colonial pendant 132 ans
l'algérie a été soumise un système
profondément injuste et brutal ce
système un nom c'est la colonisation et
je reconnais ici les souffrances que la
colonisation infligée au peuple algérien
alors que l'algérie fait la 50e année de
son indépendance
le président français s'attelle à la
paix des mémoires
rien ne se construit dans la
dissimulation dans l'oubli et encore
moins dans le déni
la vérité elle n'abîme pas elle répare
la vérité elle ne divise pas elle
rassemble les applaudis par les
parlementaires en algérie où d'anciens
combattants indépendantistes siège
encore confiance gérard longuet estime
qu'il est parfaitement inutile de
prétendre dans une intervention de
quelques dizaines de minutes de traiter
un sujet aussi complexe que l' aventure
coloniale française
et selon roger karoutchi il y à même d
oubli quand on est socialiste en matière
de colonisation et de décolonisation
ferait bien de faire attention quand on
vient dire les souffrances tout on
comprend mais peut-être que le président
la république se serait grandi à parler
aussi des arts qui se serait grandi à
parler du drame des pieds noirs
rapatriés
près de trente minutes de discours pour
une opération séduction
dans la presse le quotidien el-watan
plus gros tirages francophones estiment
que françois hollande a fait preuve
d'une sincérité exceptionnel pour un
président français
quant au journal echorouk arabophone il
retient qu'il m'est pas venu pour le
pardon
denis baupin opération séduction ou
nouvelle page qui se tourne
non pour moi je suis heureux et fier que
le président république est tenu ces
propos clairs sur la colonisation je
pense que lille où il est un tabou est
tombé et non pourra parler maintenant
plus clairement sur l'histoire de cette
période on pourra les historiens vont
être en capacité de pouvoir aller
trouver des informations supplémentaires
pour que l'on puisse savoir à sur un
centre de de deux tragédies qui se sont
déroulées pendant la colonisation avoir
toutes les informations
je pense que aujourd'hui la porte est
ouverte même pour qu'on puisse aller
vers une demande de pardon parce que de
fait quand on veut réconcilier des
peuples moi je fais partie des 50 ans
c'est dire que nous avons une
responsabilité en effet dans ce qui
s'est passé la france a une
responsabilité grave dans la
colonisation c'est vrai il faut parfois
demandé aux autorités algériennes aussi
d'avoir un mot sur la souffrance qu'il
ya eu dans l'est dans les deux sens et
ce qui est des souffrances dans les deux
sens dans une guerre et les souffrances
et mais je moi je ne confonds pas
l'agresseur et l'agressé donc en
l'occurrence l'occupant et l'occupé le
colonisateur et le colonisé
je pense que en l'occurrence il y a des
responsabilités qui doivent être dites
elles ont commencé a dit de façon très
forte très claire par le président de la
république et c'est une page importante
qui tournait aller c'était donc ce
vendredi la fin de la session
parlementaire 2012 les deux assemblées
reprendre reprennent leurs travaux le 15
janvier 2013 autant dire que vous et là
trois semaines de vacances
parlementaires
c'est l'occasion de faire un bilan de
cette année 2012 et de se projeter sur
et bien c'est le plus de l'hebdo
avec nous pour les cinq dernières
minutes donc bruno jeanbart bonjour je
travaille que vous êtes directeur des
études politiques à l'institut de
sondages opinionway
on est là pour parler de 2012 de la
projection 2013 et sens vraiment de
surprise dans votre top des
personnalités 2012 y évidemment françois
hollande on semble être une élection
présidentielle l'ua personnalité de
gagner c'est toujours celle qui remporte
l'élection présidentielle surtout dans
un système politique qui est quand même
dominé très largement par cette élection
donc c'est sûr que ces six premiers mois
c'est difficile à dire en un mot mais
bon je dirais mitigé mitigé parce que
d'abord il a quand même connu une baisse
de popularité rapide un peu trop rapide
à mon sens dans la mesure où ça ne
l'aide pas évidemment on savait que y
aurait des difficultés en fin d'année
parce que la situation économique était
mauvaise et qu'il ne pouvait pas espérer
un amélioration avant les premiers
effets de sa politique
donc il est un peu dommage qu'il ait
gâché une partie de son capital je
dirais durant l'été en donnant un
sentiment d'indécision d'immobilisme
donc ça c'est l'aspect un peu un peu
négatif
l'aspect plus positif c'est le sentiment
qu'il donne à mon avis depuis sa
conférence de presse de reprendre on
peut vraiment les choses et d'essayer
d'un j'irai de d'appliquer un cap un peu
plus clair et précis
ce qui va aussi aider les électeurs à
s'y retrouver par rapport à ces projets
pour 2013 nouveau cap aussi pour
françois hollande le changement de
méthode ou pas non je crois qu'il a il a
en tout cas envie de continuer cette
méthode probablement plus dans la lignée
de ce qu'il a fait depuis la conférence
de presse c'est à dire un président un
peu plus présent qu'il ne voulait
peut-être au début qui prend conscience
que le quinquennat l'inversion du
calendrier électoral la nouvelle
économie aussi des médias avec internet
et chaînes d'info continue font qu' on
ne peut pas être un président à
l'ancienne comme chirac ou mitterrand
complètement
année difficile il l'a dit il y aura
plus de chômage en tout cas dans les six
premiers mois ce sera très dur
oui c'est évident on savait que 2013
sera une année très compliquée la
question pour lui c est ce qui laisse
gora un sursaut et une amélioration dans
la fin de l'année 2013 ou pas mal aussi
d'un autre personnage qui a beaucoup
fait parler de lui c'est arnaud
montebourg on le disait perdant
finalement c'est peut-être lui qui va se
retrouver gagnant moi je dirais que
c'est une personnalité qui pour moi
quand même marqué des points notamment
sept en cette fin d'automne début
d'hiver parce que il a eu des
difficultés notamment arrêté avec avec
psa et le plan social sur lequel il a
été assez mises en cause
en revanche je veux sentiment que sur
mittal et la sphère florange il va
plutôt marqué des points parce que il a
donné le sentiment de vouloir appliquer
un volontarisme de vouloir pousser
mittal a négocié et c'est ce qu'a retenu
en tout cas l'opinion alors que l
inverse
les accords annoncés par jean marc
ayrault a plutôt surpris a plutôt un
petit peu donné le sentiment d'être trop
favorable à l'entreprise dont d'accord
ou pas d'animaux pas sûr aussi arnaud
montebourg en tout cas ouais je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure un peu moi ma
déception par rapport arnaud montebourg
que j'avais pu fréquenter des gens par
dit que l'état peut gagner un match la
question s'est pas fait son métier de
noter les gens en fonction de l'opinion
publique et de la communication pour ça
c'est une chose moi ce qui m'importe
c'est la politique qui est menée et est
de ce point de vue je trouve qu'elle est
beaucoup trop productiviste dans le sens
on maintient les mêmes logiques que
précédemment que prospective sur
qu'est-ce que le quels sont les
industries dont on a besoin aujourd'hui
c'est pas par hasard si la france arrive
pas à vendre c'est le prc rafale etc
ces véhicules diesel c'est parce que
nous avons des industries qui sont
tournés vers le passé nous avons alerté
le ministère le plus le plus dure qui
soit le plus difficile nous avons le
redressement brouillée
en même temps un enjeu extrêmement
intéressant c'est que c'est de se battre
quand même
mais la question la question est de
savoir si il faut être uniquement dans
une posture défensive comme nous avons
le sentiment qu'il est aujourd'hui a
essayé de contenir tous sur tous les
fronts c'est important mais aussi
d'avoir une politique offensive vers ce
qui va être le créateur d'emplois et
quand je l'entends défendre les gaz de
schiste nucléaire comme les industries
d'avenir je pense qu'il continue à
regarder avec un rétroviseur 2013 votre
boule de cristal est ce que la guerre
entre jean-françois copé et françois
fillon va se terminer là où est ce qu'on
va avoir encore ce feuilleton toute
l'année 2013 mais en fait je pense que
la guerre elle va avoir lieu jusqu'à
2016 et la désignation du candidat
c'était gênant mais ça a été la même
chose dans la période 2007 2012 pour le
parti socialiste c'est je dirais le sens
des institutions la question est de
savoir si en septembre prochain il y
aura une sorte d'accalmie dans une
bataille suivante qui se préparera mais
au moins dans une forme d'union donc
c'est surtout sa récente et pascal or là
ils se sont totalement écroulés dans les
sondages pour espérer pour eux enfin une
amélioration un petit peu l'image housse
est plombée par un endettement mon
expérience c'est que quand vous perdez
20 points en un mois vous mettez trois
ans avait regagné donc que c'est
possible pour 2017 ça me paraît exclue
pour septembre 2013
peut-être un homme on n'a pas encore
parlé denis baupin mais qui préféreront
autant d'en parler de lui pendant
l'année prochaine c'est jean louis
borloo oui jean louis borloo évidemment
qui dans ce contexte peut avoir un
espace une tentative de recréer un
fantôme moi je crois qu'il ya un espace
lorsque les électeurs ils sont toujours
là ils sont simplement orphelins la
capacité alors offrir une perspective
politique c'est tout l'enjeu de jean
louis borloo ce sera à surveiller on a
vu jusqu'à présent que la guerre à l'ump
n'a pas tellement profité aux centristes
oui mais c'est un peu trop et puis ce
sera j'irai dans les élections
intermédiaires notamment par exemple aux
élections européennes en juin 2014 que
on aura un début de réponse à mon sens
sur cette étude les vieux jean louis
borloo est élu député de l'année par le
trombinoscope ans avoue être passé
totalement à côté
il a eu le mérite vous savez j'ai fait
des choses en dépensant
ce groupe et c'est donc la russie a
constitué un groupe dans un c'est celui
qui arrive du cac a réussi à mettre dans
le même groupe
autant de partis politiques différents
donc il est là se mérite mon moi j'aime
bien jean louis enfin voilà on dialogue
on s'en remet enfin on n'a pas les mêmes
convictions
moi ce que je constate surtout dans ce
que vous nous dites c'est que l'héritage
du sarkozysme pour la droite et étables
quoi dire que il dit l'ump complètement
déchiré ne sait plus s'il veut avaler
vers le front national ou ceux restés
sur leur héritage de droite républicaine
et pendant ce temps là jean louis borloo
en effet à et raison d'en profiter pour
essayer de constituer une force
politique qui peut éventuellement demain
un jour thierry gellé l'ump oui autre
chose pour 2013 pas à ben moi ce que
j'espère surtout c'est que c'est que ça
soit le moment où vraiment le changement
que nous avons promis aux français
réellement commence à prendre toutes
envergures qu'il doit prendre est donc
là dessus par rapport au président de la
république et au premier ministre
nous attendons à des messages très
clairs sur quelle va être la grande
orientation de cette politique est-ce
qu'on considère qu on fait juste des
ajustements par rapport à la crise pour
essayer de passer l'année où est ce que
vraiment on réoriente vers la transition
écologique et énergétique juste en a
plus le temps malheureusement n'est un
petit tour de nos frontières vous aviez
angela merkel aussi vous dire que ça va
être la femme de l'année nouvelle
élection à les favoris oui parce que on
peut plus je crois regarder la politique
française sans regarder aussi ce qui se
passe en allemagne il ya en janvier un
anniversaire les 50 ans du traité de
l'elysée et en septembre il y aura les
élections qui seront importantes parce
que on a un peu le sentiment france
qu'en tout cas une partie de la majorité
espère qu' un changement à cette
occasion en allemagne avec non vous
souhaite de très belles fêtes de fin
d'année à tous et on se retrouve l'année
prochaine voilà les prochaines bonnes
fêtes à tous vers 6h20
point